في غضون ذلك وقعها وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي زعيم حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
على مصادره نحو اثنين وثلاثين مليون دولار
من عائدات الضرائب المستحقه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه وقالت ريتش انه وقع على خصم
ضعف المبلغ الذي كانت اسرائيل تخصمه من
اموال عائدات الضرائب لسلطه
الفلسطين مما يوازي قيمه الاموال التي
تحولها السلطه الفلسطينيه لعائلات الاسرى
وشهداء وفق تعبير كذلك بعد يومين من زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للاراضي
الفلسطينيه وتاكيده على ضروره وقت التصعيد
ومعارضه بلاده للاجراءات الاحاديه
وكان المجلس الامني والسياسي الاسرائيلي
المصغر الكابينت قد اقر الشهر الماضي
سلسله سلسله اجراءات انتقاميه ضد سلطه
الفلسطينيه والفلسطينيين من ضمنها مصادره
مزيدا من اموال الفلسطينيين من عائدات
الضرائب المستحقه والتي تشبيها سلطات
الاحتلال عن السلطه الفلسطينيه